there are new reports that Donald Trump
is all of a sudden significantly worried
and panicked about catching coronavirus
himself and the context is terrible
polling for Donald Trump against Joe
Biden in 2020 political failure after
failure after failure the White House is
putting in place more and more
precautions to try to protect Trump from
the virus we've seen from publicly move
on from the virus it's all about
reopening the economy
return to greatness transition to
greatness all of that stuff but the
reports from inside the White House are
that Trump is much more worried than he
has been at any point about catching the
virus himself now we know Trump is a
known germaphobe he that's been known
about him for a long time he's been
doing rallies though he's been
pretending everything's good
everything's fine but now he's
reportedly panicking so what's happening
is Trump is sending out not just
security detail with advanced teams but
also sort of like germ cleanup details
where they are determining okay this is
Trump's bathroom for this event we're
scrubbing and ultra sanitizing the
entire thing publicly they've said oh
everything's so good that at the White
House we're not low and we're no longer
doing temperature checks and regular
testing for everybody at the White House
that is true but the people around Trump
are still being temperature tests at
temperature checked and kovat 19 tested
all the time you now have a ton of
Secret Service that are quarantine after
two of them caught the virus sometimes
surrounding the Tulsa Oklahoma rally of
I guess it was a week plus ago ten days
ago now we know of a senior Trump
economic official who was in the Rose
Garden with Trump last week who now has
the virus their name is not being
released is it Larry Kudlow I don't know
but Peter Navarro it's not really clear
who it is but we know about that what I
don't understand is if Trump is really
convinced that hydroxychloroquine or as
he says it hydroxy chloroquine prevents
coronavirus why not just keep taking it
right like if he ever was really taking
it and it protects him from coronavirus
if he's so
why not take hydroxychloroquine it's
another example of how what Trump says
publicly is the opposite of what happens
privately testing isn't that important
says Trump and yet everybody around him
is tested every single day
meanwhile he's regularly golfing now I
don't actually believe that Trump
catching coronavirus would be that bad
for him politically unless it killed him
what I mean by that is his own followers
aren't likely to abandon him because he
catches coronavirus they've not
abandoned him with the testing Fiasco
they've not abandoned him over 15 cases
will soon be zero in April they've not
abandoned him over it's going to wash
through and go away like a miracle by
the end of the month if they've not
abandoned him for that why would they
abandon him because he catches the virus
on the other hand the people who
recognize that Trump has failed on the
virus they should already not be voting
for him and I can't imagine their mind
would be changed by Trump catching the
virus either do you disagree with me let
me let me know last thing in the midst
of all this there are rumors again that
Trump has coronavirus and that that's
why we've seen him tweeting recently but
not actually in public I don't even know
that that's true I mean we saw him
golfing recently would he golf with a
mild case of coronavirus I don't know
what I do believe is that if Trump did
get coronavirus but it wasn't serious
enough to put him in the hospital I
don't believe the White House would tell
us I believe that the White House would
avoid for as long as is possible
admitting that Trump has the virus again
unless it leads to him being in a
hospital for days
I think if Trump gets a mild case we
don't hear about it at all if they can
get away with it let me know your
thoughts remember I am now book Abel on
cameo at cameo com slash David Pakman or
just search for my name in the app one
of our sponsors is privacy calm they're
giving you $5.00 when you sign up for
their completely free service at privacy
calm slash Pakman I've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or
on the phone instead of actually using
your real credit card number the privacy
app and the browser plugin let you give
each company a randomized virtual credit
card number that you create out of thin
air it'll even autofill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman